.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, BRYAN, VERY
INFORMATIVE AND HELPFUL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT.
WE APPRECIATE IT
>> HERE ON MORE WITH WHERE THIS
HURRICANE WILL BE GOING FROM
HERE, THE FOUNDER OF WEATHER
BELL.COM, OUR GOOD FRIEND, ALSO
THE OFFICIAL METEOROLOGIST OF
THE SEAN HANNITY RADIO SHOW JOE
BASTARDI IS WITH US.
JOE, YOU ACTUALLY ABOUT 24, 30,
36 HOURS AGO SAID THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY THIS MIGHT COME IN
MORE SOUTH THAN WE THINK,
MEANING BELOW TAMPA.
YOU ENDED UP BEING RIGHT IN YOUR
CALL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW BAD --
>> WELL WE HAD --
>> Sean: GO AHEAD.
>> WE ACTUALLY HAD THAT FORECAST
POSITION FROM SATURDAY, WE HELD
IT.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE
WEREN'T WATCHING WHAT GOES ON.
I DON'T EXPECT -- YOU KNOW, I'M
A WEATHER NUT, SO THERE'S THIS
CONSTANT -- THERE'S ABOUT 3-5
MILLION PEOPLE THAT ARE JUST
WEATHER FANATICS IN THE COUNTRY
THAT WERE WATCHING WHAT
DIFFERENT FORECASTS LOOK LIKE SO
THEY KNOW WHAT MY COMPANY HAS
HAD OUT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF CLIENTS IN
FLORIDA, AND WE ALWAYS FELT THE
LAND FALL WOULD BE BETWEEN TAMPA
AND NAPLES, PROBABLY IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT.
IT WASN'T TOO BAD FROM FIVE DAYS
AWAY MAKING A 30 MILE ERROR IS
NOT THAT BAD.
THE THING WE HAD TO BE CONCERNED
WITH WITH TAMPA, OF COURSE, IS
ALL THE FORECASTS THAT WERE UP
TO THE WEST OF THEM AND THAT
WOULD BE SHOVING THAT SAME KIND
OF SITUATION YOU SEE IN NAPLES.
AND THIS HAPPENED IN 1921, SEAN,
AND THAT WAS THE BIG FEAR, AND
IT WAS A WELL-FOUNDED FEAR,
OKAY?
I'M NOT DISAGREEING WITH THAT.
THAT IF THE STORM WENT IN JUST
NORTH OF TAMPA, THEN THEY WOULD
HAVE THAT 15-20 FOOT SURGE UP
TAMPA BAY.
BUT YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY THIS IS
VERY, VERY DIFFICULT TO HAPPEN,
AND YOU SAW IT WITH CHARLIE,
BECAUSE WHEN A STORM IS MOVING
PARALLEL TO THE WEST COAST OF
FLORIDA, THE VECTORS AROUND THE
STORM CHANGE.
AND WE SEE THIS, AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY PAPERS ON IT DONE WITH
TYPHOONS IN TAIWAN, THAT THE
FRICTIONAL AFFECTS, IF THE STORM
IS MOVING TO THE RIGHT OF AN
ISLAND, PARALLEL TO IT OR THE
RIGHT OF A PENINSULA, IT WILL
PULL IT IN.
AND ONCE IT GETS IN, GUESS WHAT
IT DOES?
IT GOES LOOKING FOR THE WATER ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
YOU NOTICE HOW HURRICANES, WHEN
THEY'RE TO THE RIGHT OF FLORIDA,
TEND TO STAY OFF SHORE, MATTHEW,
DORIAN, REMEMBER HOW THEY STAYED
OFFSHORE.
BECAUSE THE SAME KIND OF
FRICTIONAL AFFECT ON THE EAST
COAST WILL KEEP THIS OFFSHORE.
SO WHAT YOU'RE SEEING HERE IS,
LIKE CHARLIE -- REMEMBER CHARLIE
WAS FORECASTED UP TO TAMPA, TOO,
REMEMBER?
AND WHERE DID IT GO?
IT WENT IN SOUTH RIGHT HERE
BECAUSE THE FRICTION PULLED IT
IN.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS, THIS IS
GOING TO GET TO THE ATLANTIC
COAST AND IT'S GOING TO GET
THERE, I THINK TOMORROW
AFTERNOON.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S COMING
QUICKER, A LITTLE BIT QUICKER TO
MOVEMENT ALL RIGHT?
ONCE IT GETS THERE IT'S ALL BETS
OFF OFF FOR NORTH.
THE NATIONAL HURRICANE CENTER
HAS ISSUED THE HURRICANE WATCH
FROM NORTHEAST FLORIDA TO SOUTH
CAROLINA.
REMEMBER WE WERE ON LAST NIGHT
SAYING I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS.
>> Sean: LET ME GET YOUR FOCUS
FOR ONE SECOND HERE IF I CAN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Sean: SO IT COMES IN FROM
NAPLES, NORTH OF NAPLES PRETTY
MUCH THE GROUND ZERO WHERE THIS
LANDED, WHICH IS FORT MYERS,
NORTH OF THAT SARASOTA THEN
TAMPA.
OKAY.
SO IT'S COMING IN FROM THE WEST
COAST OF FLORIDA.
IT THEN IS SLIGHTLY TURNING LEFT
HEADED RIGHT UP TO ORLANDO, AS
WE MENTIONED EARLIER, AND IT'S
PICKING UP STEAM THE WHOLE TIME,
STILL CATEGORY, HURRICANE
CATEGORY WINDS WITH IT.
SO STRONG WINDS, STILL DANGEROUS
FOR PEOPLE.
THEN IT MAKES ITS WAY MORE
EASTWARD TOWARDS THE EAST COAST
OF FLORIDA.
THEN IT GOES INTO, WHAT,
JACKSONVILLE, PONTA VEDRA THEN
WHERE FROM THIS SAVANNAH UP TO
CHARLESTON, SOUTH CAROLINA?
>> WELL, THE CENTER DOESN'T GO
IN THERE.
YOU KNOW, I CAN'T ADD TO WHAT
THE OUTSTANDING PEOPLE BEFORE I
CAME ON HAVE SAID ABOUT WHAT
IT'S GOING TO DO.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN -- UP INTO THE
FLORIDA COAST.
WHAT THE CONCERN HAS BEEN AND
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO TELL
PEOPLE IS, THAT NORTHEASTERLY
WIND THAT'S RAMMING 30-40 MILES
AN HOUR INTO THE NORTHEAST COAST
OF FLORIDA ALREADY IS PILING
WATER UP.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE SYSTEM
GETS OFFSHORE AND IS A HURRICANE
AGAIN AND COMES NORTHWARD?
THEN YOU'LL HAVE THE STORM SURGE
FROM THAT COMING UP THE COAST.
IN THE MEANTIME
>> Sean: WE HAVE TO MOVE ON BUT
I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION.
NORTH OF JACKSONVILLE, BECAUSE
IT WILL GO TO JACKSONVILLE AFTER
IT GETS OUT OF CENTRAL FLORIDA,
THEN DOES SAVANNAH HAVE TO WORRY
AND WHAT PARTS OF SOUTH CAROLINA
DO WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT?
>> YES.
YES.
SAVANNAH, CHARLESTON ALL THOSE
PLACES, I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
GET HIT BY A HURRICANE.
AND THE COMPOUNDING PROBLEM WITH
THE STORM SURGE IS THE
PRE-EXISTING WATER PILING UP.
I'M SORRY I'M SO ANIMATED ABOUT
IN.
>> Sean: NO, I KNOW, FOR THOSE
THAT DON'T KNOW, JOE IS A STORM
CHASER, HE EATS, BREATHES AND
SLEEPS THIS, KNOWS EVERY
STORM -- WHAT WAS THE NAME OF
THE HURRICANE, THE BIGGEST
HURRICANE IN THE 1920s?
QUICK QUIZ?
>> I'M NOT SURE 1920, BUT I KNOW
ABOUT THE -- I DON'T THINK THERE
WAS A BIG HURRICANE IN 1920, HOW
ABOUT THAT.
>> Sean: HOW ABOUT 1926.
>> ONE YEAR THERE WASN'T A BIG
HURRICANE.
WELL, THE 1920s WINDOW WINDOW
HAD A LOT THROUGH SOUTHERN
FLORIDA, 1929 CAPE HURRICANE,
AND 19 27, THAT WENT INTO
SAVANNAH AFTER HITTING SOU